le chien est le meilleur ami
de l'Homme. Et cette amitié
s'exprime de toutes sortes
de manières, comme celle
de percevoir les odeurs de façon
extraordinaire. Ce qui nous rend
de bien grands services.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Aéroport de Beyrouth,
mardi matin. Des voyageurs
arrivent de partout à travers
le monde. Certains reviennent
bien malgré eux avec un bagage
indésirable : le virus
de la COVID-19.
♪ ♪ ♪
Parmi la foule, cet homme
n'est pas un voyageur.
C'est le docteur Riad Sarkis.
Depuis un an, il a mis sur pied
un test de dépistage
plutôt insolite.
- On a une machine
extraordinaire qui bouge,
qui est adorable, qui est
variable d'un laboratoire
à l'autre, qui peut avoir
des couleurs différentes,
avec une fourrure, qui s'appelle
"le chien de détection".
♪ ♪ ♪
- On a l'habitude de voir des
chiens détecter de la drogue
ou des explosifs, mais
peuvent-ils flairer la COVID-19?
Le Docteur Sarkis est chirurgien
digestif et oncologique.
Il travaille depuis 12 ans
sur la détection des maladies
à partir de leurs
effluves cutanés.
- A chaque fois qu'il y a ce
qu'on appelle une "pathologie",
il y a toute une guerre
entre notre corps et
l'agent extérieur.
- Quand un virus pénètre dans
notre corps, nos globules blancs
s'activent pour le détruire.
Ce combat génère des déchets
qui se retrouvent ensuite dans
les fluides de notre corps.
Pour les chiens, ces déchets
ont une odeur spécifique.
(halètements)
- Et c'est là que l'idée m'est
venue : est-ce que j'utilise
les urines, la salive, les
larmes ou les matières fécales?
Je me suis dit : je vais voir
si je peux trouver quelque chose
au niveau de la sueur.
Et finalement, c'était
magnifique parce que l'odeur
axillaire donc, sous le bras,
est une zone qui porte toutes
les effluves et qui ne porte pas
de virus. En d'autres termes,
j'ai pris une zone qui donne
des effluves sans contagiosité
pour ne pas présenter mon équipe
de travail à la contamination.
- Good boy! Good boy!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une fois son idée trouvée,
le médecin s'est associé
à des vétérinaires et
des entraîneurs canins.
Ensemble, ils ont recruté des
chiens avec des caractéristiques
précises : un odorat fin et
une bonne endurance au travail.
Carlo Selman est
l'un des entraîneurs.
- Le chien doit être testé
à fond : s'il travaille
ou ne travaille pas,
s'il est intelligent, s'il aime
obéir, s'il aime la détect.,
s'il aime le jeu.
S'ils n'aiment pas le jeu,
ils ne peuvent pas détecter.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Voici Sky, une femelle
malinois âgée d'un an.
Active, intelligente, joueuse et
affectueuse, elle a le profil
de l'emploi.
- Sit!
- Aujourd'hui,
avec son maître Christian,
Sky apprend à identifier
la signature olfactive
de la COVID-19.
- On entraîne mon chien d'abord
à reconnaître les spécimens
positifs. Une fois qu'ils ont,
dans leur olfaction, inclus
dans la bibliothèque olfactive
les odeurs des effluves de
la COVID-19, à ce moment-là,
je vais introduire les négatifs.
- Chaque fois que Sky renifle
un échantillon positif, elle
doit l'indiquer à Christian,
en s'asseyant. Puis, elle reçoit
sa récompense.
- Yeah! Good girl! Yeah!
Ça devrait...
C'est le cas positif.
Et les autres sont négatifs.
- Pour l'humain,
ces échantillons
ne sentent pas grand-chose.
Mais pour Sky,
l'odeur est immanquable.
- Un chien, c'est ma machine
diplômée d'expertise
de détection olfactive.
(halètements)
- Ce qui donne aux chiens
cet odorat 100 000 fois
supérieur à celui de l'Homme,
c'est d'abord son museau.
Ses muqueuses nasales sont
tapissées de cellules
olfactives.
Il y en a 40 fois plus que chez
l'humain. Ces cellules captent
les molécules qui composent
l'effluve et envoient un signal
au cerveau. Le lobe olfactif
du chien est surdimensionné par
rapport à celui de l'humain.
- Donc, même une odeur d'une
petite cuillère de farine
dans deux piscines olympiques,
le chien est capable
d'une goutte d'eau nous
confirmer qu'il y a
de la farine là-dedans.
♪ ♪ ♪
- De retour à l'aéroport,
le Docteur Sarkis et son équipe
y ont installé une unité de
détection, à l'abri des regards.
- C'est une unité cynophile
qui est complètement séparée
des passagers. C'est un vrai
laboratoire.
(halètements)
- Après quelques semaines
d'entraînement, les chiens
commencent leur travail.
- Easy!
- Les échantillons de sueur
sont d'abord récoltés sous
les aisselles des passagers
à l'aide d'une compresse.
Chacune est ensuite placée dans
un pot, puis le pot est installé
derrière un cône. Et c'est là
que les chiens doivent
sentir l'effluve.
- OK... Find it!
Find! Find! Find! Find!
This way...
Good boy!
- On cherche à ce que le chien
soit bien dressé pour ne pas
rater aucun positif. C'est comme
ça qu'on peut contrôler une
pandémie au niveau d'un pays.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Au Liban, comme dans plusieurs
pays, les voyageurs doivent
fournir un test PCR négatif,
mais ils repassent quand même
sous le nez des chiens.
- On est en train de détecter
des gens qui sont négatifs
à la PCR. Les chiens nous
confirment qu'ils sont positifs
avec la technique cinophile.
- Comment expliquer
la différence entre
les deux résultats?
Les tests d'amplification
en chaîne par polymérase,
dits "tests PCR", peuvent
générer jusqu'à 30 % d'erreur.
Les chiens sélectionnés
pour le travail ne dépassent
pas, eux, les 5 % d'erreur.
Et non seulement les chiens
repèrent la maladie avant
l'apparition des symptômes,
mais ils sont aussi
plus efficaces pour détecter
les cas asymptomatiques.
- Good boy! Bravo!
- Qu'en est-il des passagers
porteurs des nouveaux variants?
- Maintenant, à chaque fois
qu'on a des variants,
j'introduis avec mon équipe,
donc, cinotechnique les odeurs,
donc, qui pourraient être
un tout petit peu modifiées
pour garder une bibliothèque
complète dans la cervelle
de mon détecteur. C'est très
intéressant parce que la PCR,
il faut beaucoup travailler
les protéines pour aboutir
correctement donc à un résultat.
- Et les chiens renifleurs
de COVID ont un autre avantage :
la vitesse.
- C'est pas comme la PCR
où on va attendre 2-3 jours
pour l'avoir. Là, en une minute,
on peut savoir qui est porteur
des effluves de la COVID.
- Cette rapidité permet
à chaque chien de tester
de 500 à 800 personnes par jour.
Les chiens ne remplacent pas
les tests PCR, mais ils sont
un outil de plus pour contrôler
la pandémie. Au Canada,
des chercheurs espèrent
que le gouvernement
emboîtera le pas.
- Si on a, par exemple,
dix chiens à Montréal,
on peut faire passer facilement
5000 passagers par jour.
- Jusqu'à maintenant,
le projet à l'aéroport de
Beyrouth est un franc succès.
- C'est très rare d'avoir
un scientifique qui croit,
qui croit vraiment en les
qualités olfactives du chien.
Docteur Sarkis y croit
et il a raison d'y croire.
- Le Docteur Sarkis voit grand :
à l'avenir, il souhaite amener
des chiens détecteurs de COVID
dans les écoles, les hôpitaux
et les centres commerciaux.
Ce médecin passionné des chiens
espère que cette approche
novatrice sera utilisée
partout à travers le monde.
- Aujourd'hui, les chiens sont
en train d'aider les bipèdes
à limiter la destruction, donc,
et le ravage de cette pandémie
catastrophique. Je remercie
beaucoup les chiens.
- Quant à Sky, son entraînement
tire à sa fin. Pour elle, tout
ceci est un jeu. Mais pendant
qu'elle s'amuse, elle apprend
à sauver des vies.